la science est sans équivoque pour
limiter le réchauffement de la planète à
1,5 degré et ainsi assurer un futur
viable pour les générations à venir il
n'y a plus de place pour l'expansion des
énergies fossiles
crossroads
action
l'utilisation du charbon du pétrole et
du gaz doit être réduite respectivement
de 100 % 60% et 70% d'ici 2050 par
rapport au niveau de 2010 9 selon les
scientifiques le sommet des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre qui sont toujours
en croissance devrait être atteint en
2025 et d'ici 2030 chuté de 43% le défi
est colossal mais la bonne nouvelle
c'est que des solutions efficaces sont à
portée de main il nous dit que jusqu'à
10 % des émissions des gaz à effet de
serre peuvent être retirés si on arrête
de subventionner l'industrie pétrolière
et depuis 2010 le coût de déploiement de
l'énergie solaire et de la production
des batteries lithium-ion ont diminué de
85 % celui de l'énergie éolienne a
baissé de 55 % de quoi convaincre les
gouvernements d'aller dans cette
direction un chemin que le canada
pourrait tarder à prendre s'il approuve
le projet pétrolier extracôtiers baie du
nord à terre-neuve-et-labrador
mais le ministre de l'environnement lui
défend sans détour la feuille de route
adoptée par son gouvernement nous sommes
le seul pays au monde à avoir pris
l'engagement de mettre un plafond sur
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
secteur du pétrole et du gaz et une
femme un grand producteur de pétrole et
gaz nous sommes le deuxième plus grand
producteur de pétrole et de gaz au monde
alors je pense que nous faisons preuve
de beaucoup de courage secrétaire
général de l'onu n'a pas manqué
d'envoyer un message clair à ceux qui
résistent
d'activité
économique
et si l'argent a l'habitude de mener le
monde le rapport du giec confirme que
sur le long terme il est tout aussi
rentable d'investir dans des solutions
vertes et que le coût humain de
l'inaction devrait convaincre les
sceptiques le giec dit encore une fois
cette fois ci que le coût de la
protection du climat est inférieur au
coût des dommages que l'on pourrait
éviter si on se mettait à protéger le
climat les solutions sont nombreuses et
touche toutes les sphères de notre vie
de la gestion de l'étalement urbain à
nos modes de transport et jusqu'au choix
nos aliments l'outil pour y arriver des
scientifiques utilisent et de la
psychologie comportementale
autrement dit comment convaincre tous et
chacun de faire sa part au quotidien le
giec mentionne l' architecture des choix
qui est un outil en économie
comportementale qui permet en facilitant
les choix un adoucissant la transition
de grimper la même montagne mais avec
une pente un peu plus facile
la sobriété devrait maintenant guider
nos choix ici elisa série radio canada
montréal